foreign
thank you
thank you
I'm so honored to meet you in person I
thank you I'm honored to meet you too
you've had so much discipline in your
life yeah you know what it's like I do I
have an infallible work ethic I do I
love it I've worked since I was 11
months old in diapers I am tireless wow
11 months yeah well I've been doing this
since I was in the stroller but dang you
got me beat girl I
maybe in that one area I do wonder do I
have you beat on like a cheat day when
you let loose what does it look like
what's a lazy day in your world like
what do you do
um so you mean like food wise or just
every whole day okay I don't know I will
try to wake up late but it's hard to
wake up late when you have a kid yeah
like nearly impossible I literally just
had to ignore Olympia this day because I
was exhausted I literally slept for like
almost a day it was crazy
um but okay so I would I would sleep in
and then I um I don't know I love to
watch lots of TV shows like what yeah
I'm big on binging
me too what are you watching anything
cheesy you know I don't like serious
stuff I love action because it's fast
and it's like usually has Happy Endings
I love a happy ending and then
um what else would I do I mean I love
chips but I'm not allowed to eat chips
because I did this test and I I came up
red on jibs and it's like really so yeah
I just would rest all day watch a ton of
TV I there's some days where I just
don't leave the house and like I
probably would when I say don't leave
those I mean like literally step outside
like the front door or the back door so
that's pretty intense so if you can of
potato chips what do you eat
um I'm not I don't know I eat whatever
like I mean I don't eat whatever I I'm
yeah like what's your guilty pleasure
what if you're like I don't care if
there's a red check next to it I love to
bake and I refuse to bake gluten-free so
I do have a gluten allergy but it's not
like I'm not Celiac or anything so I
absolutely love baking and I just draw
the line I do not bake gluten free and I
will eat it and I just suffer for like a
few hours and I'm good you know
um do you like baking with your daughter
I do actually I do not oh how so and I
and one day hopefully she doesn't see
this but I do and I really love it but
like she puts things everywhere I'm like
the flower give me a cup of flour I'm
just like oh yeah I'm just like oh don't
it's okay yeah that it's no worries but
okay let's get you know and it's just
like over and over and I'm just like
okay
it's frustrating inside but outside I
just try to keep a good face and now I'm
teaching her now that she's a little
older I'm like okay well be careful
because if you make a mess you have to
clean it up then she fell in love with
the vacuum cleaner
Olive's really into like toilet cleaning
right now right I mean that's about it I
support it I bought a bunch of supplies
and she was like yeah that's her latest
hobby it'll be something next week but
yeah life is messy with kids it is now
is it true that you didn't want Olympiad
to go to matches because you were afraid
you would lose Killer Instinct
[Music]
foreign